hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation Protea genomics and
cancer biology insights for prognosis
and therapy
presented by dr. Karen Rolla director
and professor biological scientists
division Pacific Northwest National
Laboratory
I am execute ears of laberd's and I will
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
will respond to your questions via email
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the ask
a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Rutland I would now turn the
presentation over to her thank you for
attending this seminar and delighted to
have this opportunity to explain you the
new field for genomics and how it can be
applied to cancer biology to produce new
insights for prognosis in therapy the
first question is why proto genomics
why ad proteins new genomic information
well part of the answer is that if you
look at tumors they're characterized by
a very large number of genomic changes
you can see these figures from the TCGA
lag ship papers on ovarian and glial
blastoma cancers and you can see that
there are many many somatic copy number
variations in these tumors question is
which of these are important which of
these genome level changes are actually
driving
type of cancer so our hypothesis was
that if you actually looked at protein
expression in addition to mRNA
expression in genome level changes you'd
be able to identify those things that
were functionally important and really
driving the malignant behavior this work
was published two years ago and self the
visual abstracts on this slide as well
so our first target was ovarian cancer
and you might ask why ovarian cancer
well a Berrien cancer is truly a
Disney's of chromosomal instability the
Cancer Genome Atlas found nine recurrent
mutations none of which was dumb than
other than p53 113 local copy number
aberrations and over 150 a promoter met
relations so it's a real problem to
tease out which of these are important
the other crucial issue with ovarian
cancer is that it has a really horrible
survival if it's not discovered until
stage 3 for the survive the five-year
survival rate is less than 40 percent
but it's 90 to 95 percent if it's
detected in stage one or two
problem is ovarian cancer is
asymptomatic the most women are
diagnosed with stage 3 4 so anything
that we can do to understand response to
therapy or the early detection of this
disease will improve the quality of life
for these women
so I'm also being talked to you about a
consortium the clinical proteomic tumor
analysis consortium which took on the
task of adding protein level
measurements in the genome level
measurements of the Cancer Genome Atlas
characterization of ovarian cancer and
so we partnered with Johns Hopkins
University to do this analysis on 84
tumor samples 32 of which were done
jointly at both institutions now it's no
fun to do a proteomics or mass spec
experiment unless you have a question to
ask unless you're trying to compare two
different states otherwise you're just
in collecting but the prognosis in
ovarian cancer is so horrible that it
was easy to go into the survival data
the TCGA had on the
women and select two different cohorts
those that had really poor clinical
outcomes and died in less than a
thousand days we called these the short
survivors and those women who had very
good clinical outcomes and survived for
greater than four years because these
the long survivors and we were very
interested in the proto genomic
characteristics that distinguish between
these two behaviors because we would
like to be able to treat the short
survivors more aggressively with
non-standard treatment though the
emphasis in our approach is on
information flow and we've all seen the
central dogma of molecular biology that
you start with DNA and transcribe it
into RNA and then the RNA is translating
the protein and protein does the work
but now we all know it's not as simple
as that
we have replication of DNA we have
reverse transcription of RNA to make DNA
we have epigenetic changes to DNA that
are mediated by proteins that actually
determine which genes are turned on or
off and we have RNA that's self excising
and that has enzymatic activity so it's
really much more complicated than we
thought so the question is what should
we actually measure should we measure
the DNA sequence mRNA abundance protein
abundance or protein activity when we
tried to measure all of these so what
did we actually measure in this study we
measured copy number variations we
measured DNA methylation we measured
transcription by both microarray
technologies in RNA C we didn't limited
proteomics and TCGA with reverse phase
protein arrays and we also did micro
rna's and we had clinical metadata
related to the initial diagnosis the
follow-up diagnosis and overall survival
so the basic plan was to integrate all
these pieces of information look for
correlations between the DNA level
changes the mRNA the protein the phospho
of tides as well then do functional
enrichment of the results and come up
with functional insights as to what was
coming on we had a very large data set
to start with we had over 3,000 proteins
almost there
thousand copy number variations in over
3,000 mRNA transcripts so this is an
example of how adding the protein
information really helped identify those
copy number variations that have the
greatest impact on the phenotype of the
disease so the figure on the Left shows
a correlation between protein abundance
and copy number at a particular locus on
all 22 chromosomes and I'm going to use
my pointer to illustrate things the red
diagonal is FX insists so if there was
an amplification of a gene number at
that locus there is also an increase in
protein abundance there was a donation
of that locus there is also a decrease
in protein abundance when we see a very
nice hiss of X which of those are
important here we have the vertical
effects where we saw proteins on other
chromosomes that increase in abundance
when there is an amplification or
decrease in abundance when there was a
definition we call these trans effects
and there a particular gene locus acting
at a distance on other teams usually
through the induction of transcription
factors or signaling pathways the
interesting thing is that there was a
lot of proteins that were identified
with this analysis and that made it
difficult if you looked at a protein
level to understand what was going on
but when we rolled it up the biological
processes we thought there was a
selection or transferring innate
proteins that were associated with
proliferation the utility invasion or
with immune regulation and these are
three of the ten hallmarks of cancer so
it's basically showing that no variant
cancer out of all the different ways you
can make a malignant cell there is a
real emphasis on proliferation motility
invasion and immune regulation and these
observations have held up even in a
completely and the respective set of
samples the other advantage of using
protein level functional information is
that it has more information
contact so the slide on the left is an
analysis of survival by transcriptomic
subtype and by proteomic subtype they've
pretty much agreed although we found a
new protein level subtype that we need
miss terminal subtype but it was present
only a small number of patients only
five that one subtype looked like it had
poorer survival compared to the other
four too small to really tell
statistically but you don't see any
strong trends jumping out at you and the
clustering level however when we took
the signatures that we got from the
trans affected proteins and trained them
on the survival data for the patients we
came up with a machine-learning
generated signature that had a very high
statistical power for determining
between long survivors and short
survivors and this trend held up in
prospective analyses so functional
relationships are also very strong in
terms of controlling the association
between mRNA transcription and mRNA
translation and the proteins well he did
a correlation of mRNA levels to protein
levels we found a wide range of
correlation coefficients for the same
chain at the mRNA level and the protein
level in the same tumor and they'd agree
by functional importance so those gene
products that were associated with
metabolism with immuno add metabolism
nucleic acid metabolism and immune
regulation were very tightly correlated
between mRNA and protein but those
functions that were really housekeeping
functions like ribosome production and
splicing of RNAs those proteins appeared
to be made in g2 and they just hang
around and there is very little
correlation between the protein and the
mRNA so this is just an illustration
experimentally again of one of the
observations from the cell cycle that
we've known for different so function
analysis works it gives us more
information and what is different about
functional analysis
it really is a focus on pathways so the
whole hypothesis was that by focusing on
half weights we need more information to
what is working in a tumor and I have a
nice little analogy that I like to
present and I'm drawing an analogy to
the brows or air traffic for an airline
how do you get from San Francisco to to
New York well the first slide here shows
you a map of all the air routes in the
u.s. for United Airlines all the
different ways you can get on a knighted
Airlines carrier and yet from one side
of the country to the other side of the
country that my friends is the Chingam
of the airline
however on any given day not every route
is being used at any given time that is
the transcriptome the proteome of the
airline what is actually happening I
call the fossil podium of the airline
which airline airplanes are actually
moving from San Francisco to New York
and unwrapped and this is the fossil
podium of the airline in health on a
normal day I happened to be thinking
about this from winter storm Jonas
struck in East Coast you can see the
radar the nasty snowstorm on the East
Coast and this is a disease thing for
the airline business you can't get to
New York notice not only do we not have
flights going to New York but we've
disrupted and changed the balance of
information flow to Chicago and to
dallas-fort worth there are far fewer
planes going to Chicago because they
can't connect to the East Coast there
are far more planes going to Dallas for
Organ Denver so the point here is that
the disease process is not a one gene
one protein process it disrupts the
entire flow of information in the cell
and we wanted to capitalize on this by
studying the classic hernia and so we
looked at the relative abundance of
phosphorylation on the same protein in
short survivors and long survivors
so we normalized amount of cross
correlations the abundance of the
protein but we called something up
regulated and phosphorylation there were
more phosphorylation events per molecule
with protein and not a simple increase
in the number of protein molecules which
had the same degree of phosphorylation
and when we did this analysis we could
see that there was a distinct increase
in phosphorylation all whole in the
short survivors compared to the long
survivors but if we did an enrichment
analysis for the top most highly
phosphorylated pathways we came up with
a short list of pathways that you can
see European shift receptor beta event
receptor on some cytokine receptors rack
which is associated motility and you can
see that increased phosphorylation in
these pathways clusters with survival so
that the short surviving patients had
much higher levels of activity in these
particular pathways when we did the
combination in the integration of RNA
protein and phosphoprotein data to try
to look at all different connections of
what's going on in the cell we can see
that fossa proteomics really contained
the most information so the figure on
the right is a picture of the PDGF are
baited halfway that came out is one of
the very top regulated pathways and the
little red are arrows are the
statistically significant up regulated
events and we have mRNA protein and
fossa protein here and you can see that
by and large that significant changes
are at the level of phosphorylation the
figure on the Left shows this with the
purple bars which are the most of arghya
lated pathways at the phospho peptide
level and you can see that we had far
more upgrade pathways identified by
phosphorylation than by proteomics or by
transcriptomics although they didn't
correlate we had both measures now you
might ask the question well why look at
why do this globally why take the time
and effort to look at every protein in
every foster person why not you just use
our key
pa reverse phase protein arrays or other
antibody based methods as TCGA did
originally well this is a comparison of
the results from the TCGA samples with
the rppa acid and with global
comprehensive fossil proteomics so the
two results are very congruent those
proteins that were on the RB pasa
behaved the same in that regard as they
did with local gossip on omics but you
can see how much more information
content we had with the global analysis
and how we were able to not only see
staff and MEC and earth but we were also
able to fill in the gaps and see that
the main input in these pathways was the
PDGF receptor not the EGF receptor not
the met receptor not the insulin growth
factor receptor for the case you have
our baton subject this is very important
now if you want to develop therapeutic
you go after this pathway because you
need to know how many nodes are truly
involved so you can target the right
notes so the next application for proto
genomics is really precision medicine
it's taking this information and using
it to guide therapy of the patient so
the classic model I can use classics or
something that's only been around for
five years but the standard incarnation
of precision medicine is to start with
preclinical data throw it into some kind
of an analytical engine and kind of
artificial intelligence neural network
grind and bind type of analysis and come
up with treatment recommendations for
your patients so it relies very heavily
on actionable mutations in vitro
phenotyping and thus it does have some
limitations the major limitation of
targeted therapies is that right now
they're dependent on an actionable
mutation and there are only a handful of
mutations that have drugs that have been
approved by the FDA myrath and rasp out
Abel other tyrosine kinases homologous
repair deficiencies as Umbraco one two
mutations
and then the production of new antigens
for gene therapy and vaccination against
the cancer so there's only a subset of
all patients who can even be treated
with targeted therapies the second
limitation is that the initial response
rate is very high but so is the
recurrence rate almost all tumors
develop resistance and if you have
multiple mutations in the same patient
how do you know which one to target how
do you intelligently design combination
therapies so we wanted to tackle all
three of these problems for the global
proteomic and fossa for noumic approach
and expand the types of preclinical data
that are fed into the engine this is a
collaboration with Brian trigger at the
main Cancer Institute and they are
specializing in smart treatments or
serial measurements of molecular and
architectural responses to therapy so
they're taking in a very large number of
preclinical data types mutations protein
subtypes histological images functional
screens in vitro transcription of
signatures pathway activity immuno
phenotyping and in vivo models and
they're trying to come up with a
therapeutic recommendation for their
patients in acute myeloid leukemia
prostate cancer breast cancer but we're
advocating is that you add mass
spectrometry based proteomics to the mix
and you do global proteomics and partial
cornea mix the what are the advantages
of adding her.you genomics to precision
medicine trials it's really a truly
personalized approach that's driven not
only by the patient's genome but also by
their female which includes the
epigenetics the protein translation
turnover and environmental impacts of
that person as well it adds a direct
measurement of pathway activity in terms
of those protein abundance and class
correlation the deep coverage from a
global approach enables identification
interactions and crosstalk between
pathways which can help guide
combination therapy and it provides
information on post transcriptional
regulation so again we were grateful to
be funded by the National Cancer
Institute's proteomic translate
research thinners program and this was
designed to take the cardio genomic
advances with archived specimens and
apply them to clinical questions and we
had create cynical arms where we
discovered what were the key proteins
that would provide information about
targeted therapies and then that
information would be applied in a
clinical arm integrated with actual
honest-to-goodness fda-approved
clinical trials in order to actually see
whether we could make a difference in
patient outcomes by including earlier
genomic data so the one that I'm
involved with is the Pacific Northwest
National Lab Oregon Health Sciences
University collaboration for acute
myeloid leukemia and the objective of
this one is to determine whether we use
the baseline per diem and cluster per
diem in AML patients to predict the drug
response of the patient and we started
using AML cell lines we validate moved
on to validate the signatures and
primary patient samples and we want
eventually to predict the response of
the patient samples to drug response and
also predict the response of
implementations using specimens from
trial subjects so at this point we only
have Roman era data to report this is
one of the first experiments that was
done on established cell lines each one
of which has a different driving
mutation a very well known different
drive mutation okay 562 cells have the
BCR Abel fusion you can see that they're
very highly phosphorylated and
downstream substrates of the able kinase
mom 14 is a flip 3 ite mutation it's
known to be responsive to severe
afternoon and it's very highly up
regulated in proteins that are
associated with proliferation and with
the immune response hp1 which is driven
by a rasp mutation is also up regulated
somewhat and immune response genes but
it's very highly up regulated and
preparation associated genes and so this
is at the global level and the
one of the questions was can we actually
identify new substrates of the driver
mutation and give me see the expected
change in the activity in the
phosphorylation of those substrates
using Vasa for Newman
this is a reality check for the
specificity of our approach and we can
see here that looking in the k562 cells
with BCR Abel fusion Donen in this bar
that no Naples substrates were very
highly phosphorylated much much more so
than the same Abel substrates in the mom
14 in the the1 cells that last the
bcr-abl fusion but again this shows the
power of a global fossil proteomic
approach to identify specific pathway
activation events so our next objective
was to look at the dynamic response of
these cell lines to drug treatment so
treatment with drugs that we that the
cell lines were known to be sensitive to
the Satana for the bcr-abl fusion around
them for the communication commend them
for brass activation we add a fourth
cell line with a jak 3 mutation and we
treated that selling with ruxolitinib we
measured the response at baseline 30
minutes after treatment three hours
after treatment and 16 hours after
treatment and we did both total protein
and fossil protein here are the initial
results you can see that each one of the
four cell lines had a different temporal
response to their drug treatment but in
general we saw pretty rapid responses at
30 minutes that would intensify over the
first three hours and then we would see
a kind of a return to baseline 16 hours
after drug treatment some in some cases
we actually saw a decrease in some
phosphorylation events early on an
increase of 3 hours and further increase
at 16 hours so very interesting to look
at the tempo response of say the jak 3
pathway here to BCR Abel activity but
one of the very
seeing aspects of this experiment in
terms of clinical application is that we
probably get the most information that
we need out of this first half hour
treatment so one can imagine a day where
you would take a sample from the patient
treat it ex vivo for 30 minutes harvest
the cells process the proteins send them
to the mass spec and get an answer the
same day or the next day as to which
targeted therapy you should use for that
person rather than having wait days for
an in vitro culture acid so that is our
ultimate goal to add proteomics to
clinical trial design so this is just a
flowchart for to NCI funded clinical
trials and AML that we have piggyback on
to and basically these trials started
with baseline proteomics and classic or
dynamics of patient samples who were
then treated with inhibitors and they
were followed over time if they if the
Truman responded to therapy fine the
patient was kept on that therapy but if
the tumor did not respond or the tumor
occurred then there was an iterative
analysis of mRNA protein and boxer
protein to come up with the next line of
therapy so we added proteomics to these
trials so as the first step in doing
this we used actual AML patient samples
that had full whole exome sequencing
data and full RNA seek data and we
analyzed the baseline Bosko proteomics
and philosophy and proteomic profile of
these patient samples at baseline from
frozen snow pellets without any
treatment we got some very interesting
results as you can see in this
preliminary data the blue boxes indicate
the driving mutation for each patient
and you can see that there is no real
clustering by mutation they're pretty
well spread out the red boxes indicate
drug response and we can see that the
patient's clustered very tightly by drug
responsiveness particularly
responsiveness to the same drugs
so that is very promising information
that we will be able to use faso corner
mix as a prognostic tool a ther Gnostic
tool to help identify lines of therapy
for these women so we've been doing some
parallel experiments to explore the
specificity and the power of this
approach one of these studies was done
with written a novel small molecule
inhibitor of multiple kinases but that
are relevant to AML but in particular it
was shown to be a very strong inhibitor
with a very low ic50
for Iraq one in tyrosine kinase that is
known to be responsive to IL one into
total related ligands and therefore an
immune system related ligand so we went
on to do those response studies of pet
retina and our collaborator and a Priya
Agarwal was able to classify the patient
samples based on patterning of
sensitivity from highly sensitive
patients on the Left highly resistant
patients on the right we performed fossa
proteomic analysis on the same AML
samples and saw interesting clusters of
high levels of phosphorylation on
particular proteins in patients that
were sensitive to Packard them whereas a
different set of proteins showed
elevated phosphorylation and patients
that were resistant to pack retinol we
did further analysis of the phospho
peptide motif that was highly
phosphorylated in the resistant patients
or the sensitive patients and covered
some novel motifs which may be
associated with drug responsiveness in
these patients we went on to look at a
specific sub-state substrate the p38 MAP
kinase and again found that sensitive
patients showed an increase in
phosphorylation of p38 MAP kinase
whereas resistant patients showed
decreased levels of peak 38
phosphorylation so again we think that
this approach is going to be very
productive
forward identifying therapies no but
what is what you do if your patient has
multiple mutations how do you combine
drugs in a way that makes sense for the
patient who is more than one genetic
mutation well the classic way so far and
is actually not classic is very
innovative approach that came out of
Brian Richards lab and Jeff Tanner's lab
and what they have done is taken the
patient samples and cultured them ex
vivo and 96-well plates and treated them
with various drugs and looked at the
survival of the cell lines and culture
and determined in ic50
of an inhibitory concentration at which
50% of the cells died and they have been
able to calculate an index for death for
a single drug treatment and also an
index for combined drug treatments and
they were looking for synergy where the
combined drug treatments were greater
than one so you get very complicated
datasets out of that you get this kind
of matrix of interactions between drugs
and patients and it's very hard to look
at a matrix like that to me and really
decide what combination of drugs to give
to the patient so instead we went for
the pathway approach again the
mechanistic approach where you measure
the pathway 6 directly and fit them into
known curated pathway maps and and so we
are going to be applying this approach
in actual clinical trials of drug
combinations that are currently underway
using tyrosine kinase inhibitors and a
bromodomain for inhibitor so the
take-home message from these studies is
very simple genome level predictions can
be detected identified and measured at
the protein level so the central dogma
holds up and you can verify which genome
level changes are actually being
expressed in the patient's phenotype and
therefore likely to have a functional
impact the transifex of copy number
variations of protein abundance are very
interesting and actually can be used to
infer the mechanistic
drivers of cancer and of survival in
that particular patient combining all
sorts of data from the moment from the
central dogma proteome data transcript
Undine genomic that facilitates the
identification of robust sub networks
that can be associated with disease
outcome and can be used to predict the
best targeted therapy for that patient
and improve clinical outcomes so I want
to thank you for your attention and I
want to really say thank you to a team's
live worked with me on this project pro
do genomics is extremely a team sport
not only are we cleaning genes
transcripts and proteins 13e folks at
Pina nel organ Health Sciences
University and at the National Cancer
Institute that fund of the score so
thank you very much for your attention
and I will be glad to answer questions
thank you dr. Rutland for that
informative presentation we're now at
the Q&A portion of the webinar and we'll
address some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do
some now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email now let's
get started our first question is what
additional information do you get from
mass spec x spectrometry based
proteomics compared to other platforms
like our PPA well I can go back in my
slide presentation and show you that
particular figure here I think it's
really obvious that you get more
information about all of the various
components of a signaling pathway when
you use our PPA or only or soma logic or
any other affinity reagent based method
you get very exquisite sensitive
information about known targets but
you're only able to ask questions about
the known knowns with global proteomics
and global classic audio mix you get to
ask questions
about the unknown unknown or and find
out what you did not know and so this
can be very important if you have
non-standard interactions between
pathways it could be very important in
understanding the pathways of drug
resistance because if you shut down one
pathway with a drug inhibitor what other
pathways in the cell are being
upregulated to convey the same
information from the exerciser
environment the nucleus and in order to
get that type of crosstalk information
you really need to be seeing all the
adapter proteins and all the nodes that
interconnect between pathways and what
other PTMs have been measured besides
protein phosphorylation so we're
currently measuring protein is subtle
asian and we can also measure protein
with equina lection there are other labs
who have specialized quite highly in
mentoring protein like oscillation which
is really important in how the immune
system sees proteins variations in
protein like oscillation can trigger
autoimmune responses it's not an
expertise of pnnl but it is an expertise
at Johns Hopkins our partner in the
American Cancer study there are also
some innovative proposals going on to
measure oxidative damage to proteins
they leave what are called redox markers
on the proteins and we are
experimentally developing techniques
we're looking for redox damage markers
and grunts how much sample do you need
for mass spec analysis it is much more
than you need for nucleic acid analysis
because you have PCR and other
amplification methods and the antibody
based methods are exquisitely sensitive
and can get by with just 50 micrograms
or less of protein and less than 20
milligrams of burning material on 20
milligrams is an absolute minimum for us
we really like to have hundreds of
milligrams of starting material and
is a limitation if you're ending with
biopsy samples or if your uni rushes
archive samples we're gonna have time
for one more question do you think mass
spec based proteomics will ever be used
clinically yes I do
I know that right now it's an
experimental technology that the
instruments are very expensive and very
intricate and complicated and that it
really takes an experienced operator to
get reliable very beautiful results but
that's the state of the art today taking
that condition and converting it into a
simplified and a spec that does one
thing and does it well and does it in a
standard automated way such that a med
tech type person can be trained to do it
reliably and reproducibly is an
engineering problem it's not a
fundamental problem but we come up with
the assays that have clinical utility
then there will be the driver to make
the mass spec clinic friendly and I
think we'll see a day with master well
like so once again thank dr. Rutland for
her presentation I would also like to
thank lappers for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through January 2019
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event that's
all for now thank you for joining us and
we hope to see you again soon goodbye